our ongoing series what's working looks
at innovations that are paying off in
Durham North Carolina all parents are
offered a helping hand in their first
few months of their children's lives
30,000 families have welcomed registered
nurses into their homes as part of the
family connects program our dr. Tara
nurullah shows us how it's working to
help lower health care costs and raise
parent confidence Tara good morning that
seems like like one of the most
brilliant ideas I've ever heard I love
it such a great initiative Public Health
wise the first year of life is crucial
to the developing brain but parental
instincts are not always enough to take
on the challenges of caring for a
newborn
sometimes it takes a village to support
listen and embrace the entire family
[Music]
[Laughter]
Jennie Jensen is delivering some extra
care miss holder and I'm gonna give her
a little listen right to five-month-old
Cora's doorstep she's tracking pounds
and inches along with the parents stress
level we have had our challenges you
know ups and downs can you tell me more
about what was going on this past Sunday
I just felt sad before they leave the
hospital new parents like Zawadi and
Damon Walker are offered free home
checkups I think we both had the same
fear about being left our own devices
the first visit comes a few weeks after
birth was she sleeping too much also
with the breastfeeding is she getting
enough nutrients in addition to
organizing feeding and sleeping
schedules the nurses address safety
conditions in the home working with the
pediatrician if there are health
concerns but some of their most
meaningful advice covers work/life
balance and personal relationships she
took time to ask about you you together
yes she gave us tips told us not to be
afraid to reach out to our support so
that we can have some moments for
ourselves it's a very personal thing to
bring somebody into your home just about
everyone in your life
has an opinion about how best to care
for that baby we're able to provide
evidence-based information for families
that they can trust the nurses help
parents find daycare government benefits
even the safest car seat for their baby
manake con durham connect between visits
nurses stay in touch with their families
by text and phone just wanted to call
and check in and see how your weekend
was with baby Harper fielding questions
that may not surface at the doctor's
office pediatricians are wonderful
professionals what they simply cannot
have two hours to come into your home
and that's what our nurses are able to
do Duke University's Kenneth Dodge
developed family connects parents are
very anxious maybe the system worked
when mothers stayed at home full-time
but that's simply not happening very
often today and the program is paying
off for every dollar spent it's
estimated $3 in health care costs are
saved emergency visits for babies and
family connects were cut in half a
parenting is more positive and then in
the long run we found important outcomes
such as lower child abuse rates and
lower health care costs for emergency
room visits for injuries and illnesses
even experienced parents are embracing
the help three years ago
Megan Dunphy daily gave birth to her
daughter in Washington DC after the
birth of son Caden in Durham last May
Megan thought she and husband Jason
still had a few things to learn from an
expert she watched me nurse him and
provided advice on that it was much
easier than bundling everybody up and
taking my older daughter to the doctor's
with us if I had could have had this
with my daughter I would have been a
much more confident first-time parent
the program's impact is being felt
nationwide 16 communities have sent
nurses to be trained in Durham and 14
more sites are being added soon bang for
so there is government funding but also
there's funding from the state level the
community level profit organizations and
nonprofits so it's it's a group effort
but a huge public health impact from
something that's so so cool
I love I absolutely love this idea now
you pointed out that it it lowers
healthcare costs and emergency room
visits explain how that works so doctor
dodge gave a great example which is for
example if a mother sees a rash on her
child at 2:00 in the morning in the past
she might have taken them to the
emergency room now if she's connected
with a grandmother down the street in
the program she can call her up and
maybe have her tell her you know what
that's not so big a deal you don't have
to go to the hospital
also they teach family safe practices
about not putting your baby on a high up
area where they could roll off making
sure they have a crib in the home so
things like that where they avoid
injuries and accidents are there any
restrictions at all on what families can
participate there's not and this was a
really important point is that it
applies to families of every
socio-economic background every
demographic background because as they
say every family has needs every family
needs support and this is something we
don't ask for support but we are
evolutionarily biologically based human
beings that need support so I Cho I took
care of my sister growing up and even
when I became a mother I thought there
are so many things that nobody taught me
I didn't know about um you need
everybody needs help yes and and he also
makes the point outlook you know we talk
about children being the future of our
economy of our society but they're human
beings now they're part of our community
they're more demanding than ever right
now just my luck it comes 16 years
thanks and for more on family connects
and a step-by-step guide for soothing a
fussy baby go to our website CBS this
morning dot-com